wir müssen immer mehr gift in unserer
atmosphäre co2 machen wir so weiter ist
es irgendwann nicht mehr möglich für
menschen auf der erde zu leben
es gebe nicht genügend sauerstoff und es
wäre durch das klimagas co2 unerträglich
warm wie wir heute schon co2 aus der
atmosphäre speichern können erfahrt ihr
jetzt bei klick zum science fiction
um die ehe mit energie zu versorgen
verbrennen wir vor allem fossile
brennstoffe um autos schiffe flugzeuge
und züge anzutreiben verfeuern wir vor
allem schweröl benzin und kerosin um
unsere häuser zu heizen sind es gas öl
und kohle und um uns mit strom zu
versorgen sind es in erster linie kohle
und gas es ist die kohle aus bäumen die
vor millionen jahren unter riesigen
gesteinschichten begraben wurden es ist
das öl und gas aus meeresalgen die vor
hunderten millionen jahren in den
weltmeeren abgesunken sind sie haben co2
gespeichert also aufgespalten und der
atmosphäre entzogen
dadurch dass sie während ihres lebens
co2 in kohlenwasserstoff und sauerstoff
aufgespalten haben ist unsere atmosphäre
überhaupt so zusammengesetzt dass tiere
und eben menschen hier leben können
die toten alten und bäume haben den
sauerstoff in unserer atmosphäre über
jahrmillionen produziert und den
kohlenstoff in kohlenwasserstoff
gebunden und mit unter die erde genommen
wir drehen den prozess wieder um und
verbrennen den sauerstoff und pusten das
gift co2 wieder in die atmosphäre
würden wir also alles öl und alle kohle
verbrennen wäre tierisches leben auf der
erde nicht mehr möglich der sauerstoff
wäre verbrannt und in co2 gebunden hinzu
kommt dass co2 die atmosphäre aufheizt
umso mehr co2 es gibt umso wärmer wird
es auf der erde
das heißt selbst wenn wir nicht
verhindern können dass wir durch die
verbrennung fossiler brennstoffe der
atmosphäre immer mehr sauerstoff
entziehen müssen wir irgendwie
verhindern dass das co2 in die
atmosphäre gelangt und dafür gibt es
diese lösung unterirdische lagerung eine
der vielversprechendsten methoden um co2
aus der atmosphäre zu entfernen ist die
untergrund speicherung
hierbei wird das treibhausgas bereits in
den großen fabriken und kraftwerken
gefiltert und gespeichert bevor es
überhaupt in die umwelt gelangen kann
über die hälfte des menschlichen co2
ausstoßes wird in energie kraftwerken
und in der großindustrie verursacht das
gespeicherte co2 wird aus diesen
betrieben dann durch eine pipeline tief
ins erdinnere gepumpt bekommen nur
gesteinsformationen in
die das gas sicher und dauerhaft
speichern können das ganze kann man sich
vorstellen wie ein schwamm der wasser
aufsaugt in vielen kleinen löchern ist
das gas dann gespeichert
die umgebung wird anschließend
dreidimensional überwacht somit wird
sichergestellt dass das treibhausgas
weder an die oberfläche noch ins
trinkwasser gelangen kann natürlich ist
das problem damit nicht aus der welt
geschafft ähnlich wie beim
atommüllproblem verschwindet das co2
nicht sondern wird nur temporär
unschädlich gemacht ist wurde geschätzt
dass die usa allein 1 bis 4 millionen
millionen tonnen kohlenstoffdioxid auf
diese weise speichern können jährlich
entstehen dort sechs milliarden tonnen
werden also auf mittlere sicht kein
platzmangel haben und in 50 bis 100
jahren kann es gut sein dass unsere
energieversorgung beinahe vollständig
durch erneuerbare quellen gesichert ist
dann kann man damit anfangen das
treibhausgas kontrolliert wieder in die
atmosphäre zu entlassen
die technik wird im moment genau
erforscht experten geben jetzt schon zu
bedenken dass gas viel druck im
untergrund aufbaut und so zum beispiel
erdbeben entstehen können algenfarm es
ist ein vielversprechendes projekt in
genf wurde ein prototyp für eine urbane
alten farm in betrieb genommen
installiert wurde das 350 meter lange
rohrsystem direkt über der straße da wo
die co2 belastung besonders hoch ist das
system funktioniert so die alben
bestehen aus verschiedenen organismen
die wie normale pflanzen auch durch
photosynthese kohlenstoffdioxid also
kohlendioxid in sauerstoff verwandeln
bei diesem verfahren wird das
entstandene kohlendioxid also direkt
wieder zurück in sauerstoff und
kohlenwasserstoff gewandelt die algen
werden ständig durch ihre punkt auf
diese weise erhalten sie sehr viel
sonnenlicht denn das brauchen sie für
die photosynthese das co2 wird aus der
umgebungsluft gefiltert und zu den algen
in die rohre gepumpt die organismen
gedeihen und zwar ziemlich und
verarbeiten das gas am ende entstehen
sauerstoff und algen lässt die reste
wenn aber nicht einfach weggeschmissen
aus ihnen kann man bio diesel strom
medizin und kosmetik produkte und sogar
essen gewinnen natürlich muss die
technik in der alten form noch weiter
erforscht werden um wirklich große
mengen
zwei aus der luft zu filtern bräuchte
man eine riesige menge an rohren die
überall auf der welt nebenstraßen und
fabriken befestigt werden müssten
die investitionskosten wären enorm
trotzdem die alten farm ist ein rundum
grünes projekt welches beweist es geht
auch anders speicherung in den
weltmeeren über die hälfte des
kohlendioxids das wir ausstoßen wird
heute schon von den weltmeeren
aufgenommen und gespeichert
unsere ozeane dienen als natürlicher
puffer das ist zwar schön für unsere
atmosphäre hat aber auch große nachteile
für die lebewesen unter wasser mehr co2
macht das wasser nämlich sauer das ist
schlecht für tiere und pflanzen
gleichermaßen weniger aktivität
fehlbildung und sogar das sterben von
ganzen korallenriffen können die folgen
von saurem wasser sein
die idee vom professor greg rau könnte
nun zwei probleme auf einmal lösen er
schlägt vor den rauch der industrie
fabriken mit salzwasser und kalzium zu
filtern das löst das co2 auf und es
entsteht kalzium hydrogencarbonat dieser
stoff ist wasserlöslich und er macht das
wasser alkalisch also genau das
gegenteil von sauer hilft also dabei die
weltmeere wieder gesünder für seine
bewohner zu machen in gewisser weise
existiert dieser effekt schon in der
natur
er findet nur sehr langsam statt mit
relativ wenig finanziellem aufwand
könnten fabriken und kraftwerke in
küstennähe diese technik anwenden
der professor denkt deshalb dass man mit
wenig geld viel co2 aus der atmosphäre
entfernt und dahin stecken kann wo es
der natur
wer nutzt auch dies ist keine perfekte
lösung effektiv können diese methode nur
kraftwerke in der nähe eines meeres
nutzen riesige mengen salzwasser ins
landesinnere und calcium
hydrogencarbonat zurück zu mehr zu
transportieren würde viel zu viel
treibstoff in anspruch nehmen wie
dramatisch sich der durch den co2
anstieg verursachte klimawandel aus wird
erfahrt ihr hier
dramatischer klimawandel der jetstream
wird langsamer so klicks um app und zum
blog geht es wie immer hier allerdings
wie immer auch in der video beschreibung
und was meint ihr
welche der drei methoden erhaltet ihr
für am effektivsten welche hat die
chance die erderwärmung zu stoppen
diskutiert ist wie immer mit mir in den
kommentaren
recherchiert noch mal im netz was ihr
dazu findet und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran